TO SEE WHAT GOING ON THERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, FRED.
STAY SAFE.
>>> SO AS UKRAINIAN FORCES
RETAKE TERRITORY EAST OF KYIV
RIGHT WHERE FRED IS, A SOLDIER
WHO CAPTURED A RUSSIAN ANTI-TANO
SOCIAL MEDIA ABOUT THE
COUNTEROFFENSIVE.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> Translator: THE OPERATION HAS
BEEN A COMPLETE SUCCESS.
WE DECISIVELY REPELLED THE
ENEMY.
ACCORDING TO PRELIMINARY DATA,
THERE WERE ABOUT 200 RUSSIAN
TROOPS.
SOME OF THEM ARE IN THE GROUND.
WHILE OTHERS ESCAPED.
THREE TANKS AND NINE BPM.
THERE IS ONE OF THEM HERE, WHICH
IS NOW OURS.
>> JOINING US NOW IT TALK ABOUT
ALL OF THIS IS RETIRE GENERAL
PHILIP BREEDLOVE, A FORMER
COMMANDER FOR EUROPE.
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE REPORTING
WE JUST GOT FROM OUR FRED
PLEITGEN ON THE GROUND IN KYIV,
THERE ARE MULTIPLE WAYS AND
MULTIPLE INTELLIGENCE REPORTS
THAT TOLD US HOW MUCH SUCCESS
THE UKRAINIANS ARE HAVING, IN
PROTECTING KYIV AND HOW MANY
ROADBLOCKS, LITERAL ROADBLOCKS
AND LOGISTICS ISSUES RUSSIA IS
RUNNING INTO IN AND AROUND KYIV.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THE SUCCESS
THE UKRAINIAN FORCES ARE HAVING,
PARTICULARLY THERE, WILL
CONTINUE?
>> I DO.
AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON
THIS MORNING.
AND THE SUCCESSES ARE NOT ONLY
ON THE EAST SIDE AS YOU HAVE
SHOWN.
THEY'RE PUSHING THEM BACK ON THE
EAST.
IN WHAT IS THE BUCHA POCKET TO
THE WEST ALSO NEAR IRPIN AS YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT EARLIER.
A LARGE CONTINGENT OF RUSSIAN
FORCES ARE NOW IN DANGER OF
BEING SURROUNDED BY UKRAINIANS
AND CUT OFF.
AND SO THE UKRAINIANS ARE MAKING
SOME REALLY SMART MOVES, BOTH TO
THE EAST AND TO THE WEST OF
KYIV.
AND THIS IS GOING TO BE A
CHALLENGING TIME FOR THE
RUSSIANS THERE AS YOU HAVE
POINTED OUT BECAUSE OF SOME OF
THEIR VERY DRASTIC LOGISTIC
ISSUES.
>> EVERY DAY THIS GOES ON, MORE
UKRAINIAN CIVILIANS ARE BEING
KILLED.
INNOCENT CIVILIANS, WE SEE MORE
PICTURES OF IT, WE SAW PICTURES
OF IT FROM THE MARIUPOL THEATER
MOMENTS AGO.
I DO BELIEVE WE HAVE SOME NEW
IMAGES IN FROM KHARKIV IN THE
FAR EAST, WHERE THERE WAS THIS
HUMANITARIAN AID LINE, A LINE OF
CIVILIANS WAITING FOR
HUMANITARIAN AID, RIGHT IN THE
CITY, HIT BY A ROCKET ATTACK OR
SOME KIND OF ATTACK, RIGHT IN
BROAD DAYLIGHT.
THIS IS A HUMANITARIAN AID
STATION.
WE UNDERSTAND SIX PEOPLE MAY
HAVE BEEN KILLED THERE.
AND JUST, GENERAL, HOW DO YOU
EXPLAIN THESE CLEARLY CIVILIAN
LOCATIONS, CIVILIAN TARGETS,
WITH JUST NO MILITARY VALUE,
BEING HIT?
>> THERE IS NO EXPLANATION.
THIS IS A WAR CRIME, AND WE'RE
WATCHING IT PLAY OUT.
AND THE RUSSIANS NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
JUST YESTERDAY MARIUPOL RELIEF
COLUMN GOING IN WAS ATTACKED AND
THE RELIEF PEOPLE AND THEIR
BUSES AND THINGS WERE TAKEN.
AND NOW WE SEE YET ANOTHER
HUMANITARIAN CORRIDOR OR LINE OR
RELIEF STATION ATTACKED.
THIS IS HAPPENING ALL THE TIME.
AND IN THE END, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO HOLD RUSSIA ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THIS.
>> GENERAL, TO BUILD OFF WHAT
JOHN JUST -- THAT WAS THE FIRST
TIME I SAW THAT VIDEO, IT IS SO
JAW DROPPING.
YOU HAVE WARNED, GENERAL, THAT
THE MORE FRUSTRATED PUTIN GETS
BY ALL OF THESE SETBACKS, THAT
HE CLEARLY DID NOT EXPECT, THE
MORE DANGEROUS HE GETS.
SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR
CIVILIANS LIKE THOSE WHO ARE
WAITING IN LINE FOR AID?
>> IT IS GOING TO GET WORSE.
IT IS GOING TO GET WORSE AND
WORSE.
MR. PUTIN HAS BEEN UNABLE TO
MEET UKRAINIAN FORCES IN THESE
BIG FORCE ON FORCE BATTLES,
WHICH HE REALLY WANTS.
AND THE UKRAINIANS ARE FIGHTING
THIS WONDERFUL SKIRMISHING REAR
ATTACK, AMBUSH KIND OF FIGHT
THAT FRUSTRATES THE MILITARY
ADVANCE OF RUSSIA.
AND BELIEVE IT, FRUSTRATES MR.
PUTIN BECAUSE HIS ARMY IS NOT
ACCOMPLISHING HIS GOALS AND HE
GETS MORE AND MORE DANGEROUS
EVERY DAY.
AND WHEN THEY CAN'T FIGHT THE
UKRAINIAN TROOPS, THEY'RE GOING
TO FIGHT AND KILL UKRAINIAN
CIVILIANS AS YOU HAVE SEEN.
THE RISK IS GOING UP EVERY DAY
BECAUSE OF THE FRUSTRATION OF
PUTIN